Okay. Hey everyone, it's Michael Baltos
here, founder of orderflows.com and
welcome to my orderflows market analysis
for Friday, May 12th, 2017. The market
ended a narrow week, little change
Friday with the Dow just posting just a
minimal loss, fractional loss to 20,896.
April didn't show the snapback many
expected with retail sales managing only
moderate gains against a very weak
March. CPI also failed to show much life
with the core rate posting again also a
marginal increase. Weak consumer
spending and lack of price improvements
really won't be uh turning the heat up
on the Fed to raise rates at June. You
know now that's going to be uh
interesting to see because you know I
mean there were some Fed guys earlier
this week talking about three rate hikes
this year and we're talking already into
June. So you know you got 6 months and
people are talking of three rate hikes.
Not not likely. And uh before we jump in
a brief disclaimer, this presentation is
for educationalformational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital might
be lost without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle. Only
risk capital should be used for trading.
Only those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. Now, I'm
not usually a big fan of government uh
sticking their neck into private
businesses, but when it comes to
trading, you know, the government
actually does it uh to to protect the
protect investors. Again, you don't come
into trading thinking that this is your
golden meal ticket that it's going to
change your life. For many, it can, but
for all, no. um you know there there's
going to be people that lose money and
not there's only a small percentage of
traders that actually make money in the
markets. You know that's just the
reality of it. It's a very tough game
and you know I do these videos because
you know I want to educate people on you
know on ways to trade the market share
some of my insights that I've gained
over the years and uh you know just do
it as a as an educational um video. Um,
you know, again, I'm not trying to uh
not saying, you know, open accounts and
start trading, you know, but, you know,
if you have interest in trading,
hopefully you can watch my videos and
get a little something out of it. So,
the tools used in this presentation are
the orderflows trader, this is the
footprint chart that I use, and the
delta scalper. There are I'll be talking
about a couple other little uh
indicators here and there, but these are
the the main ones um that you'll see me
talking about in this presentation. So,
first uh first up, we'll talk about
crude this morning.
Okay. So, uh, where do I want to start
here? Excuse me. Still got this, uh, you
know, I'm in Asia right now and it's
just, uh, you know, the weather here is
super hot. I'd come from Chicago last
month and now I'm here in Asia and it's,
you know, being in Chicago, the weather
was, you know, in the in the 20s and out
here it's, you know, in the ' 90s every
day. And I'm just uh got this terrible
sore throat cuz you know it's air
conditioned and it's heat and it's air
conditioned and it's heat. So anyway um
we're coming into the lows here 855
and you got some imbalances stacked
imbalances appearing here. One right
here. Then another one right here. You
actually got the delta surge given a
sell as well. But really the uh you know
the key one is this again. Yeah, I could
talk about this other one that happened
a little bit higher, but I want to talk
about this. You know, when you're coming
into a low, you know, one of the things
you want to see, you know, people always
say, "Oh, don't try to pick highs or
pick lows." And again, you know, what
you should be doing is, you know, when
you're getting to highs or lows, look at
signs. Look at what the market is
telling you. Are we going to go lower or
we going to sort of um hang around the
low then turn higher? But when you're
coming into the low and you see selling
really picking up, you know, in the
sense of, you know, the delta is
increasing and, you know, stacked
imbalances, it's a pretty good chance
you're going to keep going lower. And
you do, you go down from, you know, 4760
all the way down to 4741.
You bounce up a little bit. You do have
the Delta Scalper giving a buy. It comes
back down, makes new lows. But really,
again, you know, watch when you're
making highs or lows. You know, people
always want to have levels to be trading
around. Well, the most obvious level is
going to be the day's high and and the
days low. You know, that's the first
area, the first level you can start
with. You know, you don't need to do any
fancy calculations or anything to come
up with that level, but you know, you
should be watching it. You know, what's
happening to the market when you take
out the highs or lows. You know, there's
two things. One, it could keep going
lower, or two, it could bounce and start
trading back up into the day's range.
And you know, if you can have clues as
to what's happening as you're coming
into those lows,
you know, it can give you a trading
opportunity. And that that's what
trading is. It's about finding the
opportunities.
Okay. So anyway, we hit these new lows
down here at 4736. Bounce up
here. You got the delta sc. We're giving
a couple cells. One, two. First one sort
of goes sideways. Second one's a little
bit better. Um, you know, about, you
know, not the greatest thing, but about
a 10-point tick. a 10 tick move and then
you get the three in a row setup which I
um talk about you know for the members
users of my software what you have is
ratio ratio ratio okay people always say
hey what's the ratios well ratios are
you know it reads the volume in the
bottoms of the bars of green bars or at
the tops of red bars that's why you see
numbers below green bars and above red
bars and what you're looking for is
three in a row three ratios in a row a
pullback back preferably in this bar,
the fourth bar. This one happened in the
fifth bar and you got the pullback
finally until you know this point of
control. So you know this one you know
even though it's a nice it's a three in
a row. Ideally what you would like is 1
2 3 the fourth bar to be the red bar the
pull back in between the points of
controls. this one. It sort of took a
longer way to happen
and then it shot up, you know, from 47
70 all the way up to, you know, wherever
we closed uh we got up to above 90, but
we closed at uh like 82. But, you know,
really again, you know, the one thing
that I want to point out is this here
coming into these lows. Watch what
happens when the market goes into lows.
You know, are you going to have
additional selling come in or is it just
probing down into the low? you know,
traders trying to see if there's going
to be selling coming in because that's
what professional traders do when you
get down to highs or lows. When you get
down to lows, you know, they'll they'll
test it. They'll test it. You know, is
this low going to hold. That's why
sometimes you see like, you know, very
small trades right on the lows or right
on the highs. You know, you'll see like
three lots, one lot, five lots. You
know, they're seeing if they could
trigger something. you know, if they
could start posting new lows,
you know, get other longer term triumph
traders.
I can't got I can't speak properly right
now. Um
they're trying to probe lows, you know,
print it lower to see if, you know, it's
going to trigger anything, whether, you
know, technical traders coming in, you
know, saying, "Oh, you got a new low.
Okay, let's go start selling." Or, you
know, other time frame traders saying,
"Hey, we're breaking out of this low,
coming in and start trading." you know,
that's what happens quite often, you
know, at highs or lows.
The next one I'll talk about is E-
Minis. E- minis, uh, today very, very
very, very boring session. Um, what was
the range? I think it was like 6.7
points or something. We had a low of 84
and a quarter,
a high of uh 93 and a half. So, very,
very tight range. And
you know so just you know just sort of
walk you through this going back to
about 7:00 here 7:30 after the numbers
came out you know 740 you got the price
sorry the delta scalper given a buy okay
and you know we rally up from 88 all the
way up to the highs at 91 12 but again
you know you have your look at your
volume profile it's just your your
normal day you know your normal
distribution your bell-shaped curve I
mean volume wasn't heavy or anything
like that not in the least Then you
start coming up into the high and you
know you start petering off again. You
know you're coming up into the high. You
got a small delta negative uh sorry not
negative. You got a small delta. Got the
red bar. This is the uh volto
U-turn up here at the high giving a sell
signal. Gave one earlier. It didn't work
out. This one did. And you start coming
off. You know, you see delta, you know,
selling, starting to pick up 795, 2,000
even here, right just after the cash
open minus 2,000 price rejector gives a
buy right around the point of control
for the day. Scoot back up, coming back
down.
This is the U-turn again. This is the
delta scalp. We're given a sell. Um,
again, you know, but we're in a very
tight range now. We're here in the
middle, right around, you know, right in
the middle of the value area, almost at
your point of control for the day. And
what why is that important? Well, you
know, even though you're getting buys
and sell signals, like here you had a
buy signal. This one just sort of went
sideways on you um before coming down
towards our lows. But when you're
trading around your point of control for
the day, trading around in the middle of
your value area for the day, no matter
what indicator you have, you could have,
you know, the
A+ number one indicator, you know,
that's going to pick every turning
point. But if you're in the middle of
your value area, in the middle of your,
you know, at your point of control for
the day, it's probably not going to be
very effective. Why is because, you
know, that's the area where people are
happy to trade. That's where volume is
going to trade through. You know what
people tend to forget is they take
things they they don't always put their
signals or their trading in context of
the market. You know so what that means
is you know when you're trading in value
you know that's where people are happy
to transact. That's why the markets
exist. You know markets were created so
people can transfer risk and ideally
they want to transfer risk at price
levels that they're comfortable with.
Right? And what does the market do? Does
do does sorry it moves from value area
to value area. It's constantly seeking a
new value area. But when it's in the
middle of a value area, that's where
people are going to trade. You know,
that's where people can move size. Um,
you know, I I learned very early on the
markets is are attracted to size. Why?
Because people that have a lot of size
to move need to trade it when there's
other size to trade against. You know,
you can't trade 5,000 e- minis in a
period of illiquidity. when you can when
you're going to move the market, but you
don't want to move the market. You want
to be trading it in an area where you
can move size and not move the market.
And people sometimes, you know, just
don't grasp that concept.
You know, it and it sort of runs
contrary to, you know, how how sometimes
scalpers trade. But I mean, the way
scalpers trade is, you know, they watch
the dome and they'll say, "Oh, a,000
lots just came in on the offer." and
they'll just hit the bid because they're
thinking, "Oh, that person's got
thousand to sell. They're going to sell
it down." Well,
you know, there's also traders out there
that are sitting there waiting for some
size to come in and then they'll just
scoop it up. Um, you know, the trade the
scalpers mentality is I'm going to jump
in front of the size. But the big
traders mentality is, hey, there's size
I can trade and come in and just buy it.
So those people that jumped in front all
of a sudden are short at you know seven
and you know there's the big offer at 8
each trade nine bid all of a sudden you
know and they got to cover it. So you
got to define what sort of trader you
are. You know, if you're a longerterm
institutional trader, you're attracted
to size. Markets are attracted to size.
You know, that's where the big traders
are going to come in when there's size
for them to trade. Generally, you know,
that's not always case. Oh, Mike says
always, you know, every time there's
size, big traders. No. Um, but you know,
if you're trading in an area of value
and you see big size come in, be
careful.
But, um, anyway, so we start coming into
these lows. You got it's not the low
here at this one. This is about a two
ticks off the low.
Got a couple bullish ratios and followed
by two bearish ratios
bullish ratio here. Then you hit the low
right on this low of the day.
You got a couple things. One, you got
divergence, but more importantly, you
got the delta sculper giving a buy. It's
giving a buy right on the low of the
day. And again, yeah, I'm not trying to
pick highs or lows, you know, let the
indicators determine based on the order
flow, you know, and the delta sculper is
picking telling me, hey, you know, this
is a buy. It doesn't really, you know,
the delta sculper, a lot of these
orderflow tools, they don't take into
account, you know, are we trading at
highs or lows of the day. It may take,
you know, relative to, you know, recent
highs or lows, but you know what, you
know, again, I'm not trying to pick
highs or lows of the day. You can see
this this was the low of the day 84 and
a quarter and you know we rally up from
there you know from you know 85 in the
next bar 85 and a half all the way up to
you know 89. So you're talking a day
where there was a 7point move, you know,
from the high to the low. And here's the
delta scope. We're giving you basically,
you know, from 5 1/2 all the way up to,
you know, we'll call it, you know, nine
nine and I'll say 9 and 1/2, but nine at
least or 8 and 1/2 at least, you know,
so it's at least three points there. Got
another buy here. It's a little bit, you
know, off the low, but again, it's just
sort of going sideways right here. then
you're running late in the day. But
really, I mean, the best trading
opportunity was this one around here,
9:56 this morning. There really wasn't
much, you know, when you have a day with
a range of seven points, you know, to
get a move to be able to catch a move of
three points is is fantastic.
Okay, so the next thing I want to talk
about is bonds. You know, bonds were
just rallying most pretty much all day
long. And, you know, I want to just
point out some stuff here. So, you're
coming into these highs. You got a
divergence here. You got a new high here
with the ratio. A new high with the
ratio. A high here with the delta
scalper. Uh new high here. A new high
here.
And a high up here with the ratio. But
let's just sort of walk through these
things. Okay. So,
okay. Well, here
just step it back a little bit. So, you
know, it's like every time you get a
sell signal, it really it comes right
back with the buy signal. So, here you
got the U-turn U-turn. So the first
U-turn comes back with a body, a bearish
signal, a bullish signal rather. Then a
bearish signal followed by a bullish
signal divergence that fails price
rejector and a ratio comes back with a
bullish ratio. Same thing here
ratio followed by a bullish ratio. This
is the delta scalper, but it's on a
green bar. You know, it's you need, you
know, any indicator that you want to
trade, you know, get price action of the
bar. You know, if you're looking to get
short, you don't want the bar rallying,
price rallying in the bar. Here you got
the uh U-turn. Didn't work out. Came
right back up. Didn't have a ratio. This
high, you got a ratio, bounce low. You
got the U-turn. You know, this did it
work. Yeah, it came off a little bit.
It's not the biggest uh move, but you
know, the the takeaway is, you know, be
careful if you get short on a bar. This
what I talk about. Don't get married to
a trade. You get short like here. Say
you're getting short off this. Say you
got, hey, I like the point of control
near the top. I've got the um U-turn
here. I get short. But then if it comes
back with a bullish ratio, that's your
sign to cut your loss. You know, you
don't want to be getting short. And then
in the next bar being a bullish bar,
you know, and you got it. Same thing
here, right? You're getting short off of
this ratio and this price rejector
U-turn, thinking, hey, you know, finally
we could start to sell off. Then it
comes right back. You see a bullish bar
here. You know, don't don't fight it.
You know, don't fight it. Cut your
losses. You know, this was a tough day
in the bonds today. Okay, 5 years. Um, a
bit similar. Um, you know, we're coming
into these highs. You got bullish ratio,
bullish ratio. You got a divergence that
fails. It comes back. You got a
divergence with almost a ratio. It's
27.99.
I use 28. Um, but it comes right back
with the bullish ratio. So, you know,
had I, you know, be willing to take this
cuz it's a very close number. You know,
I probably would have obviously, you
know, 27.99 and 28 is 0.01 is the
difference. Um, and I looking at the
volume, it's decent. I' I'd bite on it,
actually. But it comes right back with
the bullish ratio. So, you know, getting
short, you should just cover it, you
know, you don't fight it. Don't fight
it. When you have a bearish sign and
it's followed up immediately with the
bullish sign, um, it doesn't pay to to
swim against the tide there.
And you know, the interesting thing was
this high here, this bar, uh, 11810,
there's a tremendous amount of volume up
here, 15,000 traded on the offer, 14,000
on the bid. And, you know, it's it's not
every day you see a buying imbalance of
of 15,000, you know, or over 10,000 in
for what it's worth in the 5 years. And
to me, that that is important because,
you know, you got a lot of time. You
know, this bar took about 15 minutes and
you just turned a lot of volume through
there. Yeah, honestly, I would have
bitten and I'd be looking for a little
bit of a pop higher. It only got managed
about four or five ticks higher before
coming off and just going sideways the
rest of the day. But still, you know,
you see
um you know, some buying up here. But
again, you know, why would I be
interested in this is because you know,
I know there's a lot of sellers here and
if you get past that,
where's the resistance? All right,
where's the resistance? It's not, you
know, again, you know, the scalpers that
come in and seeing size coming in on the
offer here or they're selling it down.
They should be selling here looking to
well then they're not hitting the bid.
They'll probably be well, they probably
would or they'd be working, you know, 9
and 3/4 trying to be as smart Alec
thinking, oh, there's a lot of size
here. It's going to hold down the
market. But again, if size in certain
markets,
size attracts size, right? You can't
move size unless you have size to trade
with. And when I say that, what I mean
is you can't move size and not move the
market unless there's size there. Um,
you know, if well, you don't there's no
trading floor anymore. But, you know,
you remember, you know, back in the days
when, you know, there'd be guys on the
headsets and you have the squawk box.
Oh, there's uh, you know, Goldman's is
offering, you know, 300 bonds at 18 and
then, you know, it comes off trade 17,
16, comes back up to 18. someone just
lifts all the the 18s and you know
there's a lot of traders out there big
traders you know they they look for the
size to trade against and you know don't
be lulled into the sense that just
because there's size there you got to
jump in front for the market to come off
you know again you know if you had
jumped in front of here and you sold it
you know a tick ahead of this uh
what was that uh 18 and 118 10 and a
quarter you're selling tens
you know, thinking, "Oh, I'm safe. You
know, I got this size to hide behind."
Well, by the time you it trades there,
gets lifted and turns bid there. You
know, you're
going to buy it back. You know, it's 5
years, there's going to be 3,000 on the
bid ahead of you. You know, next thing
you know, you're thinking, well, you
know, there's size up there at at 10 and
a half. I could, you know, hide behind.
So, anyway, so you turn to, you know,
what you were trying to scalp, you know,
maybe two ticks out of this market to a
three tick loss. So, just be careful
with that. you know that that's my only
bit of advice.
Okay, just really quick. This is the
Euro currency. This is a six range
chart. And you got this high up here
again. You know, 21 trade. Second time
you trade it, you trade one lot. And I
like that. I like it when you come up
and you test a high or test a low. The
second time you get less volume and it
doesn't get any smaller than one lot,
you got a ratio. Market comes off. To
me, that's a high percentage trade when
you test a high or test a low and second
time you do it with a lot less volume.
just shows you buying is uh in this case
buying is drying up. If it was a low,
selling would be drying up and we come
off quite nicely. You do get the price
uh delta scalper here, but it's a red
it's a red bar. I'm not really
interested, you know, even though it
shoots up a little bit um over the next
few bars. Now you're getting up here.
You're testing this high here. You got
the delta scalper giving a sell. It
comes back up two bars later. Then you
get delta scalper again. You know, this
one it trades a little bit lower.
off the high, you get the delta scalper
again, you know, next couple bars, it
trades a little bit lower. Then you get
a buy here, makes new highs here, you
got a sell,
goes sideways. Um, then later in the
day, you know, 10:30,
got a few things going on in here.
You've got,
what do you got here? You've got this uh
this is the delta surge giving a buy,
you know, right up towards the high. But
then, you know, two bars later, three
bars later, you got a delta surge giving
you a sell. This is the delta scalper.
Not interested on necessarily on on a
red bar on a sorry, on a green bar for
getting short. But in the next bar, you
got the delta
surge giving you a nice sell here. So
again, you know, you could be getting
short here in the next bar and it it
makes a nice little move lower. This one
doesn't work out. This is the delta
scalper. doesn't work out there. Um this
is already 3:00 on a Friday afternoon um
right ahead of the close. So yeah, there
was
there was some nice short-term
opportunities there in the Euro currency
this morning. Okay, so this next chart,
this is a no, sorry, that's the wrong
chart. Uh serial currency I talked about
already. Looking for the Japanese yen.
Okay. Um well, I'll talk about the
British pound. Um I can't find my yen
chart. I think I closed it by mistake,
but anyway, um this is the uh British
pound. You know, people have been asking
me to show other currencies
and
you know, so here's the British pound.
You know, same things, you know, exact
same things you're looking for. You've
got, you know, the delta surge given a
buy right here. You get a nice little
move higher. Yeah, the this is the price
rejector at the swing high. You have do
have an imbalance here. Now on this
chart right now when you're looking at
imbalances, okay, you can set them to
whatever levels you want. And when I say
set them, what I mean is the thresholds.
So like on this chart, okay, I have the
imbalance threshold set at one. So as
long as there's at least one contract,
it'll show up like two against 17
though, you know, to me is not
important. When I'm talking about the
threshold, what I mean is
a minimum of certain amount. And usually
for my charts, I have it set at 50.
Okay, so I want to see 50 lots. But some
of these currencies, yeah, you do have
very thin areas here. Like you see, you
got imbalance two against nine, one
against five. Is that an imbalance? Yes,
it is technically. But for my analysis,
I don't really want to consider it.
Although I do have it set that way to
show up. Um, you know, I I normally I
would set it at 50, but again, for
currencies,
I I change it to one just, you know, for
my own personal preference. But you know
generally you know on my other charts
you know bonds 5 years e- minis things
like that I haven't set at 50. Um so
again you know while two against nine is
an imbalance you know for really for
um an analysis uh purposes you really
shouldn't concentrate on that being an
imbalance. Like even here you got 0
against 49. Okay 5 against 34 1 against
24. Well, you know what? If I have my
imbalances set at 50, minimum volume
threshold of 50, these this stacked
imbalance is not going to show up. And
to me, that's important because, you
know, when I'm looking at imbalance, I
expect there to be good volume
and, you know, the imbalance to be, you
know, whatever percentage it is. So,
again, you know, if you have it set
lower, you're going to get a lot more
imbalances. That's why you see um
numbers here, you know, one against 18,
um, you know, one against five, four
against 17, two against 11.
But anyway, I'm not going to talk much
about imbalances on this chart, but I'm
going to talk about, you know, some of
these indicators. So, again, you know,
the same things that you're looking at
on on, you know, any other chart. You're
also looking on, you know, the other
markets. So, what do you got? You know,
you got the delta surge giving a buy.
You got the price rejector giving a
sell. You got point of control down here
at the bottom, which is bullish. Point
of control up near the top here, you
know. So, we trade from this little this
area up to this area back down. You got
Delta Scalper giving a sell here. the
U-turn giving a buy.
Then you get up into these areas,
excuse me.
You know, you've got single print,
single print, you got price, sorry,
delta scalper cell, delta scalper cell.
And you know, the first one just went
sideways, but again, you know, the
second one a little bit more actionable.
I mean, they're both actionable. Um,
it's a nice move down from, you know, 0
the the 0304 area down into the 8384
area. Um, Delta Scalper giving a buy.
This one didn't work out.
Then down here, you got Delta Scalper
giving you another buy. Again, it's a
nice move from the 29 area up to where
we close around 29 uh 128
uh 88890
level all the way up to the uh 12902
level.
And
let's see anything interesting in the
boons. I don't remember anything
interesting in the boons today, but you
know, I'll just just run through it.
So you got a high here. Okay, this
sometimes this cash close around there.
You got the high with the ratio and the
divergence. You do sell off a little
bit. Another high with ratio and
divergence. Come off a little bit going
into the close. Um anything else? Delta
scalper there. Delta scalper price
rejector here. It's a nice little move
though again. You know, it wasn't the
biggest range today. This is the price
rejector here.
Stacked imbalance here. didn't work out.
It's a nice, you know, four level
stacked imbalance
up here. You got ratio with divergence
comes back up within a tick within
another tick before making that move
lower. So, you know, this was a nice
one. Um, again, giving a nice low entry
trade. You got point of control ratio
and uh divergence there. Here you got
the same thing where this one didn't
work out. It just came right back with a
bullish bar. Again, like I said, you
know, don't get married to it. You can
see immediately in the next bar, it's
coming back with a bullish a bullish
bar. You get out.
Um, that was about it, I think.
Yeah, this is 7:30 this morning. 7:16.
you know, this price, sorry, Delta
Scalper giving a sell there. Come down
in here, you got a nice ratio. You've
got the Delta Scalper giving a buy, but
again, it's right ahead of the number.
Uh, lastly, let's talk about beans. I
don't think there's beans are also quiet
today. Beans, all you really had was
this this high with the divergence. It
did come off, but again, I don't like
taking divergences, you know, just
because it's a divergence.
um you know earlier on the low there
just after the the open the reopen
rather you have this dogee bar you got
the negative delta
again for me I just sort of I don't want
to say I overlook dogee bars but I find
them for orderful analysis to be just
kind of neutral
people say well you missed the trade
here well yeah okay I missed it um
there's a lot of other markets to be
trading but you know really there wasn't
a whole lot to get excited about in the
beans today here price reject uh sorry
delta scalper giving us a buy but it's
on a red bar here. You got to buy,
you know, just went sideways on you.
So,
oh, let's just look at this other
indicator, the transition. Let's see how
it did today. This is the mini dow. You
know, I've been showing the mini dial.
You know, if you're a short-term trader,
I got these orderflow indicators which
can help you out. This is the
transition. Gave a nice little sell
here. Nice sell here. Nice buy. A nice
buy. This this one you shouldn't have
taken.
When I say you shouldn't have taken,
it's because the next bar, right? You
let the markets take you in. The market
didn't take you in.
This one probably stopped you out. This
was a nice buy. This cell didn't work
out. Stopped you out.
That was about it. A nice buy here and a
nice sell here. So, you know, you're
talking about win-win
loss win
loss. Call that a loss. Win, win, win.
Nothing there. Win.
That was it. So, you know, you're
talking, you know, over 50% easily there
on the wins on this transition in the
mini doll. It's a 100 tick chart. Again,
you know, if you're trading 100 tick
chart, you're not looking to be holding
it for an hour or two. Um, it's going to
be very short-term trading in and out.
So, anyway, um, thanks for watching this
video. Um, to learn more about trading
software I use in this presentation and
how you can add orderflow to your
trading, visit my websites,
orderflows.com and the deltascalper.com.
And I got a webinar coming out this uh
on uh Thursday. Um, there'll be a link
down down in the description. You can
sign up for it and I'll be doing some
promotion on it over the weekend. So,
thanks and uh have a good weekend
everyone.